Man, when I found this
crazy little street missile,
my mind just started
racing as fast
as this little car will rock.
Then the guys from
Borla called, and they
said they wanted to do something
extra special for the SEMA show
here in Las Vegas.
Bam.
I knew in my mind it needed
to be a Manta masterpiece.
Now, this Manta
had a safety issue,
so we built our own custom
firewall in this thing
to keep the driver safe.
Then we added a 383
stroker, and then we
did a satin black on
this car, with Borla
inspired graphics all over it.
David, my man.
Aw, yeah.
Now, David Borla,
he's here right now
to check out how this insane
little rocket came out.
David, this whole
project has been awesome.
And the fact that we get to
work together with Borla--
it's been an honor for us.
Honor for us, too.
We had a lot of fun.
It was really fun.
And when you said that
Borla wanted to show off
the new induction system
and exhaust system,
this car is perfect for it.
So I would lay a very
safe bet it's going
to be the only one at SEMA.
Yeah, I think so.
I think it's gonna
be the only at SEMA.
I think you're definitely
good on that one.
- Yeah.
- You ready to see this thing?
I'm ready.
I'm excited.
- I love it.
Come on over here.
Let's check this out, man.
Ryan, my man, bring
that Manta out!
No way.
Wow.
Look at that thing.
- I know.
Oh, yeah.
Wow.
- What?
- Yeah.
Nice.
Smooth, yes.
Come on.
All right.
Oh, man.
That came out
really, really nice.
It's perfect.
Excellent.
This car had potential
when we got it.
We've done a ton of work to make
her SEMA ready-- some planned,
some not so much.
We started on the inside by
upgrading the transmission,
then we added that
custom Borla induction
system and exhaust
system to make her look
and sound awesome.
After Ryan did a
little surgery to make
sure it fit like a glove, he
finished off the whole racecar
vibe with a satin
black and red Borla
inspired color scheme
that we matched
with an all new red interior.
This car is ready for SEMA,
and ready to hit the streets.
And I just hope the
world is ready for her.
Tell me what you're
thinking, brother.
When you went to cut
this thing, I was nervous.
Oh, I know.
I was like, you
get one shot at this.
Yeah.
And it's gorgeous.
It's perfect.
Everybody went nuts
making sure that induction
system just shows off.
It's easy to
take it for granted
because it looks like it's
supposed to be like that.
Right.
But making it look
like that is not easy.
- No.
- No, it's not.
You guys did a
great job with it.
Not at all.
You know, and doing
a full color change
on the car in the satin
black seemed to make the car
lower and wider, which I love.
- Right.
We completely
re-did the interior,
all in that red leather.
It complements the
Borla graphics on it.
So we've got a really cool
vibe going with the whole car,
but when this thing is
sitting in your booth,
she's going to be open.
- Yep.
We're going have it open.
So let's show this off.
This is how tight everything is.
We've literally gotta
take the first two
stacks off to get it open.
She is close.
And ba-ba-ba-bam.
Wow.
This is what I'm
talking about, right here.
I mean, there it is.
It's all just right there.
Absolutely.
This is why I
thought this car would
be the perfect car to show off.
[inaudible]?
It's almost like having it on
a stand, and this is the stand.
Right.
No, exactly.
It's all just right here.
Absolutely.
Your exhaust system here, the
headers, the tubes, whatever
you want to call this-- they're
gorgeous, and so correct,
it's unbelievable.
This is why people
come to the SEMA show.
For this, right here.
- Amen.
I mean, this is it.
Amen.
Last time when you saw his car,
it had these pop up headlights.
Headlights.
Which I just hated, so we
completely changed the face
of it by properly putting
old school Can-Am racecar
style headlight setup in it.
Looks great.
Fixed headlights.
It looks, like, so sexy, too.
That's the right headlight
setup for this car.
100%.
The shape of this
car is everything.
Yeah.
Add the Borla logos on
there, and it does look
a little bit like a Batmobile.
It just made it that
much cooler to me.
Right.
The car is so much fun that
it will be a real attraction,
and attention getter
at the booth at SEMA.
But man, once the
people enter the booth,
and they get to see what
you guys have got going on--
Oh, my lord.
It's going to get
a lot of attention.
You gonna be happy to see
this baby sitting in your booth?
So happy.
So proud.
We've been to 30, 40 SEMA shows.
This one's going to
be the best one ever.
I gotta say, man,
this little Manta
has been nothing but difficult,
but an extremely fulfilling
build.
She's really wicked.
She came out awesome.
She's got my stamp of
approval, and now on top of it,
I've got David Borla's
stamp of approval.
It's time to go to SEMA.
Off to the big show.
David, I'm glad
you're happy, man.
- I'm so happy.
- This thing is sick.
You know, when she's
sitting in the booth, open--
Perfect.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
It's got the name all
over the back, brother.